hello everyone my name is Kevin Collins
I am the director of point of care
Global Marketing for Siemens Healthcare
and I will be the moderator for this
webinar
Siemens is pleased to be part of the
fifth annual clinical Diagnostics and
research online conference
our speaker today is Dr Monet sayag who
will be presenting on the role of
lactate in the assessment of morbidity
and mortality
sepsis including severe sepsis and
septic shock are common today and are
associated with substantial mortality
and the consumption of significant
Health Care Resources it is estimated
that 18 million cases of sepsis are
reported each year worldwide this is a
very important issue that hospitals deal
with every day I'm sure you'll find the
presentation most interesting
our speaker today is Dr Monet sayag
Dr salyg is a senior medical and
clinical consultant for Siemens
Healthcare Diagnostics
he received his Bachelor of Science in
biology and chemistry from the
University of Mobile in Mobile Alabama
he is a bachelor of medical technology
from Anderson Memorial Hospital School
of medical technology in Anderson South
Carolina
he also has a master of science in
Health Sciences from the American
University School of Graduate Studies in
Coral Gables Florida
and finally Dr Syed earns his doctoral
medicine degree also at the American
University School of Medicine and Coral
Gables
his postgraduate training is in the area
of general surgery with emphasis on
emergency non-trauma minimally invasive
laparoscopic laparoscopic surgery from
the University of Southern California in
Los Angeles California
Dr salyak has 25 years of experience in
the fields of medicine research surgery
and Clinical Laboratory science
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
you to Dr Monet sayag
thank you uh Kevin and welcome all of
you for this educational webinar
um lactate has been around for quite
some times uh however its value in Risk
stratifying a number of disease States
it's still expanding
it was first discovered in the 18th
century when it was isolated from sour
milk
in the early 60s uh Huckabee wrote one
of the earlier papers on the
significance of hyperlactidemia in
hospitalized patients
and the body of evidence supporting the
value of lactate measurements have been
grown ever since
in a normal steady state with adequate
tissue resources and oxygenation
they're more cellular energy can be
extracted aerobically by means of the
citric acid cycle and the electronic
transport chain
in this case cells convert
pyruvate to acetyl-coae through
oxidative decarboxylation
when the body experiences an inequity
tissue perfusion
it undergoes anaerobic metabolism to
create some energy even in small amounts
in this case pyruvate metabolizes to
lactate ultimately generate fewer atbs
normally 2 versus 36 atps
then though the normal aerobic mechanism
let's keep in mind that even under
normal conditions this process
occurs to some degree however lactate in
normal human subjects clear very quickly
at a rate of up to about 320 millimoles
per liter per hour
mostly by liver metabolism and
reconversion of lactate back to pyruvate
lactate production occurs in all tissues
namely skeletal muscles brain red blood
cells and kidneys
a systemic imbalance between oxygen
delivery and demand cause lactate levels
to sharply rise both in experimental and
clinical conditions
Lactaid levels are long been used to
reflect the presence of tissue hypoxia
and hypoxia results in cell death and is
not resolved leads to organ failure and
ultimately death
but rather than thinking like it solely
as a byproduct of an inadequate blood
perfusion it may be useful to consider
Lactaid as a marker of strained cellular
metabolism
patients with sepsis trauma
volume depletion blood loss
septic shock and systemic inflammatory
syndrome can have altered lactate levels
while lactate is a very non-specific
marker
knowing lactate levels particularly
early in patients presenting
early inpatients presentation can uh
valuable can give us or provide us
valuable information to help guide
patient assessment and treatment
the College of emergency medicine has
developed a quick user's guide to health
Physicians understand Lactaid values
while there are limitation to its use
likely levels should be used in the Ed
as a diagnostic guide and septic
patients
if above normal levels
there is cause for concern
like the values are essential in
identifying tissue hyper perfusion in
patients who are not yet hypotensive but
at risk for septic shock
also erase lactate level especially in
the rate of clearance when we look at
the rate of clearance as the prognostic
value for survival
as the user's guide from the College of
emergency medicine notes normal levels
of Lactaid in healthy subjects range
from somewhere between zero to two
millimoles per liter
elect a level greater than two
millimoles per liter is a cause for
concern
and if sepsis criteria are already met
this indicates severe sepsis
and as Negan in this uh paper noted
blood lactate concentrations greater
than four millimoles per liter are
unusual in normal and not critically
ill-hospitalized patients
regardless of their underlying
comorbidities this may be indicating
septic shock if the patient does not
respond to fluid
now
repeating the levels provides a clinical
uh picture of the patient's ability to
clear lactate
after initial resuscitation using oxygen
fluids swabs and cultures antibiotics
blood tests
and urinary catheter of hourly
assessment of urinary output
the greater the level of clearance the
better
however as the College of emergency
medicine's user guide notes if the blood
pressure remains low normally the
systolic blood pressure is less than 90
and the mean arterial pressure is less
than 65 this is definite septic shock
regardless of the lactate level
well this is a two Familiar of a slide
clinician normally caring for patients
in the hospital or Ed setting they face
many challenges
the presentations of symptoms
can be confusing in addition the
progress of disease can be so rapid
pathology so severe that it is often
recognized late
eliminating the critical window of for
Early Intervention when treatment is
most likely to be successful
it is all too lost in when Healthcare
Providers have to tell a family members
that their loved one
who had appeared relatively well or on
the road to recovery perhaps only the
day before that their condition has
suddenly worsened
that patient
may be in critical condition in the ICU
or even have died
so strategies to minimize that scenario
are of Paramount in importance
lactic acidosis is frequently seen in
the critically ill patients
despite a large number of potential
ideologies
tissue hypo perfusion is by far the most
common ideology among the critically ill
patients
aggressive cardio
respiratory resuscitation
bind or designed to restore tissue
perfusion is the fundamental approach of
these patients so by monitoring blood
lactate concentration
allows for some prognostication and
indicates when supportive therapies are
restoring perfusion
here are listed the different types
that are listed for example type A
results from an imbalance between tissue
oxygen supply and demand
there are lactic acidosis under type P
lactic acidosis occurring when clinical
evidence of poor tissue perfusion or
oxygenation is absence
um it is important to know that uh as we
all know lactate measurements may be
helpful in emergency department
the or and in the ICU
now uh the concentration uh or the
concentrations of lactate and hydrogen
ions in paternal and Fetal blood
indicates their movement is from fetus
to mother and can move in either
direction so therefore maternal acidosis
will be reflected in the fetus
therefore during pregnancy
for example the umbilical artery lactate
concentration the acid-base balance can
help predict urinatal outcomes with
similar efficacy
however its Simplicity makes lactate
analysis an interesting alternate
alternative in obstetric care in
addition infants born following
prolonged or complicated labors during
which oxygen supply to the fetus is
likely to be the impaired
to be impaired and are more uh acibotic
and have significantly higher lactate
levels so in the ICU
the concentration of lactate
is an index of clinical condition of the
infant
raised lactate levels were associated
with increased mortality and ventilated
babies
a clinically important increases in
blood lactate
May perceive the development of clinical
markers of deterioration and
complication
also blood lactate concentrations May
provide an early warning signal
and important prognostic information in
the ill ventilated neonate
serial measurement of blood lactate
following open heart surgery in
pediatric patients have become a part of
a routine monitoring
in some hospitals physician use
measurements of blood lactate
to guide therapy by cardiotropic support
volume support and oral blood pressure
regulation
suggested by the fellidi in this paper
the initial acting measurements after
surgery indicate that the magnitude of
oxygen that incurred during surgery
a post-op lactate of six millimoles per
liter or above generally indicates that
the patient would require a higher level
of support
also a definite rise in lactate of any
time warrants rapid therapeutic
intervention by means of volume support
iotropic agents vasodilators or
ventilatory Support also during the
initial 24 hours following surgery blood
lactate levels should steadily Decline
and by 24 hours should be at or near
normal range
so among the criteria used to initiate
ECMO the extra corporeal membrane
oxygenation are hypoxemia that fails to
respond to Conventional ventilatory
support and bar trauma in all cases
the infant must have a reversible
disorder and be at the greatest risk for
dying
also an additional criteria that has
been proven to be of use and blood-lact
age
which may be used as a final decision
point to determine whether an infant is
put on ECMO or not
the uh
institutions of various institutions
uh when when it comes to lactate
measured before initiation of ECMO that
is less than five millimoles
uh and and declining that's usually
where they suggests ECMO may be
unnecessary but at last lactate above
five millimoles per liter it supports
the decision to go to the ECMO and
lactate is then measured early in actual
procedure usually less than one hour
then every four to six hours as a
warranted
in the normal intensive care and the
normal intensis patients uh when they
are admitted to the hospital with
lactate level of four or higher
they face uh an in-hospital mortality
close to about 40 to 50 percent
because the patient's blood pressure may
be relatively relatively normal uh and
these patients at least initially it is
important to look for metabolic evidence
of tissue perfusion and measuring
lactate is a relatively effective way to
do that
if we uh look at researchers uh and
papers
they're looked that
aggressively these patients must be
treated and who had a normal blood
pressure but an elevated lactate the
group's mortality rate was 16 lower than
the control grew
their Apache score were also
considerably lower so the patients
admitted to the Ed was clinically
suspected infection
those with normal blood pressure
increased blood lactate level greater
than four millimoles per liter per
associated
with a 10 times higher mortality rate
than normal lactate levels
mortality around 26 or 27 percent
early recognition of trauma patients at
risk for developing infectious
complications is a very difficult task
diagnosis of infection can be
troublesome
positive bacteria bacteriological
specimen may be laid or absent
the clinical interpretation of local
colonization may be ambiguous
additional infection makes such a core
body temperature and the WBC may show
non-specific alterations
because admission lactate level
measurements have been shown to
correlate with fatal outcome and organ
failure in trauma patients
in this paper the author tested the
theory that initial acted level could
help differentiate between patients with
eventual septic cores and those without
it
Fiddler town this paper confirmed that
initial lactate levels helped
differentiate patients with an eventual
septic course versus those without it
they also determined that
changes in lactate values over the first
24 hours provided a tool to identify
patients at risk for developing an
infections sepsis and death
failed or insufficient lactate clearance
usually less than 2.5 or always below
2.5
millimoles per liter in this paper
within 24 hours is associated with
longer Hospital staying in ICU stain and
increased duration of mechanical
ventilation
okay why I'm showing you uh this picture
this is a doctor
Tim butman as a as a known uh professor
of surgery in Emory University
uh indeed
um described this microbe or the respond
of what we refer to it as the cytokine
storm
uh there is an interesting book by Sir
William Osler a Canadian pathologist
educator and a historian
uh wrote this book The Evolution of
modern medicine
describing the cytokine storm
and eventually that is initiated by
either infectious or non-infectious
agent that led to sepsis uh septic
septic shock and ultimately death
and
the basic mechanisms of of the septic
process is very heterogeneous
it was believed
that sepsis was an exaggerated
hyperinflammatory response with patients
dying uh from inflammation
induced lung injury more recently
findings indicate that significant
heterogeneity exists in the inflammatory
responses of septic patients
at this point the literature clearly
illustrates that no single mediator
system pathway or even pathogen drives
that drives the pathophysiology of
sepsis so the basic mechanisms of septic
processes are multifactorial
this regulation uh coagulation altered
hemostasis prolonged clotting times
there's certainly a variant mediator
production
hyperinflammatory blunted inflammatory
response and unknown inflammatory
response
cellular dysfunction many cellular
aspects become dysfunctional
in sepsis
and maybe characterized as either
excessive activation or depressed
function
there are metabolic alteration
these alterations patients usually who
are critically ill exhibit insulin
resistant and hyperglycemia a condition
known as the diabetes of stress
but it is conversion controversial there
are issues with hypoglycemia as well as
the costs associated with disclose with
closed monitoring also low-dose steroid
versus high dose of glucose steroids
have not shown an improvement in outcome
and have been associated with an
increased risk of death so evidence does
exist that some patients with sepsis
have adrenal failure and these patients
benefit from replacement doses of
glucocorticoids administered a prolonged
period of time
but the early goal directed therapy as
was demonstrated by rivers ital that
early administration of fluid and blood
products
significantly improved survival
substation or septic patients in the
emergency department
let's look at Lactaid in surgery
patients
so the systemic inflammatory response
syndrome as we refer to it serves is
common in the post-op period of of the
critically ill patients so uh sir Kelly
uh Italian this uh in his investigation
uh he correlated between lactate levels
multiple organ dysfunction and mortality
in patients with sirs
uh using uh the cutoff of two millimoles
per liter at the inclusion of the study
the relative risk of death in seven days
was around for uh 4.23 and a 28 days was
1.7
and the
Le which is the uh lactate elevated
using a cutoff uh uh or using the cutoff
of greater than two millimoles per liter
had a seven day mortality rate of
approximately at 39 which is
significantly greater than for patients
with normal value of Lactaid those
mortality was around nine percent
the 28-day mortality was 46 percent the
Le group and 20 in the normal lactate
level less than
two per liter
selected in severe sepsis uh described
by Arnold it tell he wanted to determine
in this paper if early lactate clearance
is associated with improved survival in
the emergency department uh when those
with severe sepsis and the concordance
between central venous oxygen saturation
optimization and lactate clearance
during early sepsis resuscitation
as you can see
while lactate
lung clearance occurred in only 15 of
the 166 patients approximately nine
percent
the author found that early lactate
clearance was a strong predictor
of in-hospital death
the cause of an elevated serum lactate
in patients with sepsis
can be multifictorial although an active
elevation may result from acute tissue
hypoperfusion and anaerobic metabolism
other possible causes may include uh
sepsis induced impairment of the
pyruvate dehydrogenase enzyme activity
there are also increased lactate
production via catecholamine driven
pathways
or decrease lactate clearance due to
hepatic dysfunction however regardless
of the etiology as you can see an
elevated serum lactate
or lactate elevation sepsis has been
consistently linked to increased
mortality
111 patients were enrolled with the mean
age of about 65 years of age
in the emergency department the length
of StayWell somewhere in between six to
nine days and an overall in hospital
mortality rate was around 42 percent the
Baseline Apache score was about 20 and
lactate was about 6.9 plus or minus 4.6
um this uh study uh by Nagin again
looked at uh 111 patients
um in the emergency department
so why I'm showing you this uh this is a
formula for lactate clearance very much
used all over the country
and and worldwide lactate clearance
or the percent was defined using this
formula at the AV presentation normally
you know Zero Hour where patients
present to the emergency department
so minus lactate at our six divided by
lactate the Ed presentation they
multiplied by 100 so you have basically
lactate levels at presentation and you
minus that from uh you know six hours
later the level divided uh by the uh the
lactate level app presentation times
100. so a positive value denotes a
decrease or clearance of lactate it's
good a negative value denotes an
increase in lactate after six hours of
Ed intervention that's not good
now
survivors compared with love survivors
had a lactate clearance of 38 percent
versus uh 12 respectively
there was an approximately 11 decrease
in the likelihood of mortality for each
10 percent increase in lactate clearness
and interestingly in this study Nagin
saw and compared other variables such as
slightly counts Prothrombin time albumin
bilirubin and only lactate clearance
showed a significant difference between
survivors and non-survivors
the high lactate clearance group
has a 52 percent relatively lower in
hospital mortality rate compared with
the low clearance group
and this mortality difference was
similarly observed up to about
60 days
so let's look at uh you know circulatory
shock and some of the common parts of
circulatory shuttle
they are hypovolemic shock due to
dehydration fluid loss or blood loss
the body initially responds by
vasoconstriction to maintain adequate
blood pressure
cardiogenic shock due to decreased
cardiac output from a variety of causes
the response to this vasoconstriction of
the arterial arterial circuit and
pulling of blood in the venous circuit
on the other hand septic shock
characterized by both early and late
stages it's important to focus on those
two stages the early stages early the
cardiac output is increased and shunting
of the blood from the arterial to the
venous circulation
this may result from a bacterial
endotoxins that causes vasodilation in
some areas and vasoconstrictions in
others
also there are serious problems
occurring if the areas would decrease
blood flow our organs with a high oxygen
demand such as the brain kidney and
liver
on the other hand laid septic shock is
characterized by decreased cardiac
output basal constriction and edema so
patients seldom recover from the
advanced stages of sepsis so really the
whole idea is we hopefully but avoid
that late septic shock at all possible
cost
it is important to detect any of these
shock States early so that the therapy
can be most effective
in this paper Bakery towel concluded
that blood lactase reliability indicated
that the effectiveness of therapy and
either oxygen
deoxygen deoxygen oil related to blood
lactate
also there were documentation that only
11 percent of patients with expressed or
it's fast lactate concentration that is
greater than 4 million moles per liter
survived circulatory shot
others demonstrated that as lactate
increases from two to eight millimoles
per liter the estimated probability of
Survivor decreased from 90 percent to 10
percent
Kevin uh went through some of the stats
around the country uh and also certainly
worldwide uh there are uh rather
alarming numbers uh 18 million cases of
sepsis a year
750 000 in the US with severe sepsis
cases per year
uh the mortality in the U.S for severe
sepsis is somewhere around 38 percent
uh the U.S severe sepsis uh costs around
17 billion dollars a year
and uh hospitalization uh contribute
approximately two percent for sepsis
the radius of your sepsis
hospitalization have doubled
in the last decade the incidence of
increase has increased by 1.5 percent
per year
as a result of several uh contributing
factors that I'll mention the medical
and technological advances associated
with treatments you know IV catheters
and so forth uh the increasing number of
elderly or debilitated people or
patients with underlying diseases such
as cancer who require therapy and also
the widespread use of antibiotics which
encourages the growth of drug-resistant
microorganisms all of these contribute
to this High increase
incidence of sepsis
so who's at risk
you know we don't think uh you know or
that uh the healthy uh is is immune from
that uh really there are several risk
groups uh listed here including those uh
uh that are shown uh but all uh at risk
we're all at risk for for early uh
sepsis or we are certainly uh uh even
healthy in the previously healthy are
subject to these uh
massive uh sirs and ultimately sepsis
and so uh it is important to keep in
mind that
um the statistics uh that we see three
cases for a thousand of total population
that's just to put in a perspective
the risks rise with age and the
incidence is increased as the population
ages
so 55 of septic patients have a
significant comorbidities
um there's some data estimated that 12
are copds uh another 12
non-metastatic neoplasm six percent
patients so the HIV about five percent
of metastatic neoplasm and 43
mortality Associated sepsis and
metastatic neoplasm
so the annual estimated U.S death
putting it in a prospective uh let's
look at the severe sepsis alone there
are severe sepsis alone kills more
people annually in the U.S than lung
colon breast cancer and stroke
this data shows a 28-day mortality uh in
in an Italian study of the ICU patients
a mortality risk increases from source
to septic shock
uh 27 and as we move to the right sepsis
at around 36 mortality in severe sepsis
closer to about 52 percent mortality
rate and then septic shock it approach
reached about 82 percent reality these
numbers vary depending on the study but
the trend is very consistent
you know Studies have shown
very similar results but yet you can see
as we Advanced from septic shock the
mortality rate increases
uh with septic shock and severe
substance associated with the highest
mortality risks and the ideal biomarker
should be indicative of a mortality risk
let's look at the mortality associated
with a septic shock more closely
the vertical axis plus the odds ratio
for death and the horizontal axis plots
time to therapy
as shown in this graph
delaying and from microbial therapy
results in an increasing risk for death
so the Shaded area is the 95 percentile
competence interval
time is the enemy
in a patient with septic shock the
survival rate drops approximately 7.6
percent every hour so pathogens are more
likely a gram negative around positive
bacteria and fungi
so let's look at the definition of
systemic inflammatory response syndrome
how do we Define that
service is defined as the presence of at
least
uh
two uh commissions uh the following uh
areas two conditions the defining
conditions are white blood cells
respiration temperature and heart rate
best definitions has been widely
criticized because it is very broad
however it has been a useful uh for
clinical study
now on the other hand
the definition of sepsis
is is defined as proven to be
information or confirmed or suspected
infections so
it has to be either confirmed or you
have suspicion that there is infection
in the presence of service
so sirs must be present this definition
has proven to be useful in practice and
in different studies
so bacterial infection is the primary
culprit approximately 80 percent of old
cases with gram positive uh
being uh the most
common accounts for over uh 50 of all
infections
um so uh the uh combination of uh sepsis
there must be a confirmed
expected uh uh sepsis in the presence of
service that's very important
uh there are certainly other uh erodes
uh polymer crops and fungi which
comprises uh lesser percentages that
gram positive approximately 52.1 percent
of the infections of sepsis
in other words
when we look uh by far the
sepsis is is uh confirmed
or suspected in the presence of service
uh make up the definition again it's
also known that there are non-infectious
agents uh you know trauma birds patient
um many other conditions that
initiated the Cascade of events and
ultimately leads to substance so there
are infectious non-infectious agents
okay now severe sepsis and septic shock
definitions are a little different since
we've now defined sepsis which asserts
and it confirm or suspected infection
let's define severe sepsis and and uh
and septic shock
certainly uh
sepsis plus organ dysfunction is severe
sepsis
uh common
dysfunctions occurs in the
cardiovascular renal respiratory and
hepatic to be hematological or the CNS
any of these organs can be involved a
severe sepsis on the other hand
the uh
there are a hypertension despite
adequate fluid resuscitation and uh so
uh this is associated with perfusion of
romanity like for example
urea
now
until a cure for sepsis is found early
detection is the surest tool for
survival
as we've seen in the sepsis literature
the earlier it can be detected and
treated the greater the reduction in
mortality and morbidity
so an indicator of morbidity and
mortality in sepsis needs to be rapid
because
a Cascade of events can be rapid with
death occurring in about hours as little
as 24 to 72 hours
the early goal directed therapy and
septic patients can decrease mortality
by as much as 46 percent
every hour of delay lower Survival by
nearly eight percent
and the global sepsis Alliance urges the
use of antibiotics and intravenous
fluids within an hour of suspecting
sepsis
survivors of sepsis are at risk of
developing mental and physical
impairments late in life
sixty percent of subsist patients
experience worsening of cognitive or
physical functioning or both Factor
their infection nearly 17 showed signs
of moderate to severe cognitive
impairment compared to six percent
before the sepsis infection
also uh sepsis contributes to 20 000 new
cases of cognitive improvements such as
dementia per year
let's look about a little bit of whole
blood versus serum particularly when you
draw blood I think it's critical to
understand that from a laboratory
perspective
so lactate is moderately unstable once
it's collected
as I mentioned very early uh the earlier
slides that cellular glycolysis can
increase lactate but indeed it can
increase it by zero point uh four
millimoles per liter in a whole blood
kept at room temperature for 30 minutes
and by about 0.1 millimoles per liter is
kept on ice for 38 minutes
so if blood is preserved with fluoride
and oxalate
lactate is much more stable
lactate increases by no more than 0.1
millimoles per liter in a whole blood
stored at room temperature for 30
minutes or at 4 Celsius for 8 hours so
sometimes the selections of preservative
you know anticoagulant tubes is
important there were no statistically
significant difference between the
lactate concentrations
derived from blood samples for healthy
healthy subjects store in sodium Heparin
EDTA or lithium heparin so they like the
concentration of blood stored in sodium
citrate however was lower than that of
all other coagulations or anticoagulants
uh when the two samples one obtained for
example from sodium Heparin and no
anticoagulant were centralized at 50
degrees or 10 degrees Celsius for 15
minutes to obtain plasma and serum
samples the plasma and serum lactate
were consistently higher than the whole
blood values so again there is very
critical when you measure your lactate
to choose the appropriate anticoagulant
tube and to make sure that not
compromised with the results in patients
with a known hyperlactidemia those who
had the concentration greater than 2.2
millimoles per liter uh there was a
difference of about 0.14 millimoles per
liter between plasma and whole blood
there was no difference in plasma or
serum samples so plasma or serum
determinations require extra step of
centrifugations which increases
technical time slightly delays reporting
of results
further the delay in performing the
essay also allows for live page shifts
to occur between plasma blood cells
compartments and for uh the plasma
lactate to increase the ongoing lactate
synthesis by uh blood cells so a delay
by as much as 30 minutes may increase
slightly concentration but as much as 70
percent
please keep that in mind
so there have been numerous studies of
other markers and while the added value
to the clinical picture they don't
really address the need for early
detection of sepsis
the use of single measurement of venous
lactate that can be available rapidly
following admission
so the Ed provides the clinicians with
better risk assessment possibly with
clear direction to diagnosis and therapy
than vital signs the predictive uh Power
of lactate levels was indeed was
independent of blood pressure and cool
variance in about 375 trauma patients
admitted to the emergency department and
increased lactate level greater than 2
millimoles per liter was a better
predictor of morbidity and more
mortality than physiological triage
criteria
this is composed of heart rate and blood
pressure
Glasgow Coma Scale and respiratory rate
so traditional resuscitation in points
such as viral signs fail to definitely
address the severity of global tissue
hypoxia and thus our pool reflection of
the resuscitation and the development of
organ failure and death
while previous literature may have given
the notion that directed care of septic
shock patients require invasive
measurements such as pulmonary artery
pressure oxygen delivery index and
systemic vascular resistance a more
recent investigations support testing
mortgage more easily acquired in the Ed
such as mean arterial blood pressure
central venous pressure and lactate
levels
when the clinical index of Suspicion is
high that a patient may have or may
developed sepsis
time is of the essence
so the need for an inaccurate and Rapid
result is per month and can be achieved
with a whole blood sample
I'm showing you here the uh basically
the protocol for the early directed
therapy in septic shock
uh this model has been used
all over the best level of evidence we
have for fluid resuscitation is septic
shock comes from this early
goal-directed therapy trial this is
published by rivers and and colleagues
in 2001 and this study uh they're
approximately
263 patients with septic shock or severe
sepsis with hypoperfusion they were
identified upon Survivor to the
emergency department and randomized
to receive either static fluid
resuscitation
a normalization of the mean arterial
blood pressure central venous pressure
and urine output or early goal directed
therapy in which the same measurement uh
resuscitation goals were met but there
are additional goals were based upon
measurement of the central venous oxygen
saturated as indicated there
the central venous oxygen saturated
saturation served as a surrogate a
measure of tissue perfusion and oxygen
delivery and when abnormal in these
patients resulted in the transfusion of
red blood cells and the administration
of ionotrophs in an attempt to increase
oxygen delivery and tissue perfusion
uh all interventions in this study were
conducted in the emergency department
during the first six hours after
survival
and
diagnosis
was was done also within that six after
six hours after that time patients were
transferred to the appropriate Intensive
Care Unit or for subsequent hospital
here
um there are evidence-based guidelines
for managing severe sepsis and septic
shock that have been shown to improve
outcomes uh what is essential is early
recognition of substance to facilitate
early initiation therapy uh obtain
cultures uh begin intravenous
antimicrobial therapy as early as
possible within one hours
initiate
an empirical therapy uh and and as
certainly should cover all of the likely
pathogens identify the sign of infection
and reassess antimicrobial regimen daily
uh there are results from numerous
randomized uh prospective trials that
were conducted over the last few years
they're all very similar uh those who
apply the protocol for early directed uh
for the early goal directed fluid
resuscitation you can see the sepsis
protocol implementation
there are Improvement
and decrease the risk of sepsis
once that applied
so in summary
after an exhaustive review of literature
a panel 55 International expert made
several recommendations
although blood lactate concentration May
lack precision as a measure of tissue
metabolic status elevated levels and
substance support aggressive
resuscitation
the surviving sepsis campaign recommends
the protocol eyes resuscitation of
patients with sepsis
induced shock
Define as tissue have a perfusion that
is a hypoperfusion
persistent after initial fluid challenge
or blood lactate concentration leader or
equal to four millimoles per liter this
protocol should be initiated as soon as
hypoperfusion is recognized and should
not be delayed pending ICU admission
based on the recommendation of surviving
sepsis campaign
and uh the data we have covered the
institute for healthcare Improvement uh
concludes that if serum lactate is not
rapidly available in your institution
invest in equipment to make rapid
assessment possible this should be a
president this should be a standard of
care
create a standardized protocol to manage
severe sepsis that includes the
measurement of lactase also should
include a include a prompt on our teal
blood gas questions or Physicians
ordering entry to prompt users to
overlacted or suspect severe substance
that's particularly applies to large
teaching hospitals particularly when you
have residents just to get in familiar
with those and I think that will work
very well and so with that I wanted to
conclude by saying thank you very much
for your attention and please don't
hesitate to send your questions for Q a
thank you
great thank you Dr Sayang the
presentation was very informative
we will now take some time to answer
your questions
if you have a question please click on
the Q a button
and then type in your question and then
we'll answer it in the order in which it
is received
right now we have no questions so uh Dr
Syed I I will ask a question while we
wait for
um
some questions to come in and my
question to you is this
lately procalcitonin has been receiving
a lot of attention
uh and my question to you is how will
procalcitonin work with lactate
in to improve the management of sepsis
in the hospital
excellent question uh Calvin uh as you
you know you may very well know uh that
uh procalcitonin has been uh studied for
quite some times as well not as much as
lactate with but it is considered to be
a a marker of an early substance the
early stages of sepsis I think that's
exciting I think uh it will work
harmoniously uh you know with lactate
level uh I think the approach of
biomarker approach that has been truly
uh a blessing with other disease States
you know you can look at the cardiac
aspect of it uh you know using for
example troponin and BNP and Etc I think
uh using a combination of biomarkers
particularly you know from early and
late uh stages of sepsis to cover and
and
we'll we'll uh will ultimately uh the
outcome is have been official to our
patients so I see positive impact on
utilization both markers
good thank you
so again if you have a question please
click on the Q a button and type it in
and we'll be happy to answer it
we'll wait a few more minutes and if we
don't have any questions and we'll we'll
thank everybody and let them go
uh
there there is a question on my side
um Kevin may I read it sure yes
uh you mentioned that sepsis is growing
problem and the growth is projected to
continue what may cause this growing
problem
you know I've I've mentioned earlier
um
uh the the contribution of several
problems of growing problems with sepsis
um you know the medical technological
advances definitely are associated uh
with treatment has increased and so we
we are likelihood of exposure to more
pathogen as a you know to enter to the
body through via for example IVs uh
certainly a big factor and growing uh
you know users of catheters intravenous
lies and invasive procedures
also uh the increasing number of the
elderly or debilitating uh people uh
immunocompromise has uh has a lot to do
particularly those patients with cancer
the growing uh
problem and and the last spread of using
antibiotics I think those are the three
uh that I mentioned earlier that
contributes to the growing problem of
sepsis
okay
so so I think
Dr sayag I we don't have any questions
here I don't know if you have any more
on your end
um if there are none I would like to
take this opportunity to
um thank you Dr salyang for such a
informative presentation
um it's a very important topic uh and uh
I enjoyed it very much I'd also like to
thank our audience for their
participation and interests
we have a global audience on the phone
with us today so I'd like to wish
everybody a good morning good afternoon
and good evening depending on where you
are in the world and thank you all for
joining us
Thank You Gavin and thank you everyone
take care
bye